longtemps attendue des doses de vaccin
arrive enfin en bosnie-herzégovine
cette livraison inespérée de dix mille
doses du sérum d'astrazeneca correspond
à un don de la serbie à son voisin
balkanique qui a du mal à
s'approvisionner 5000 membres du
personnel médical pourront ainsi être
vaccinés en priorité
c'est raté dans une situation les
mécanismes globaux et multilatéraux
d'approvisionnement en vaccins ont
échoué le président vous de 6 nous a
envoyé ce gala nous l'avons acceptée je
le remercie pour tchatcher porno mais ce
n'était pas calé et est en fait celle
d'un potager dans la tente de serre
romantique vide
la bosnie n'a toujours pas pu lancer sa
campagne de vaccination dans le même
temps le pays dispose d'un des taux de
mortalité lié aux qu'ovide des plus
élevés au monde
sarajevo comme belgrade a subi les
défaillances du mécanisme onusien
d'acquisition de vaccins
kovacs nous nous attendions à recevoir
des vaccins de lieu mais nous ne les
avons pas reçu les avez vous reçu ici à
sarajevo
non vous n'avez rien reçu nous avons
obtenu à belgrade
l'on nous n'avons rien reçu nous les
remercierons lorsque nous recevrons les
vaccins du programme kovacs en mars ou
en avril
lorsque cela se produira en bosnie
chaque région gère elle même ses
commandes de vaccins candidats
potentiels à une adhésion à l'union
européenne
la bosnie herzégovine est depuis 1995 et
les accords de dayton scindé en trois
parties la fédération de bosnie
herzégovine région croato musulmane où
les relations avec la serbie ne sont que
formel c'est pourtant dans cette région
que le don de dix mille vaccin
d'astrazeneca sera distribué ensuite la
république serbe de bosnie entité serbe
qui se veut plus proche de moscou et de
belgrade
cette région s'est d'ailleurs vu livré
ce lundi vingt mille doses du vaccin rue
spoutnik v et enfin le district de brcko
territoire autonome et neutre de la
république serbe de bosnie
obtient ses vaccins d'une manière
différente du système kovacs tout comme
le ministre l'a dit dans le cadre de
kovacs nous avons payé pour deux cent
mille citoyens ou quatre cent mille
doses de vaccin nous avons également
payer pour acquérir quatre cent mille
doses auprès de la fédération de russie
et nous avons une promesse de l'union
européenne et nous travaillons également
avec les chinois pour obtenir des doses
du vaccin chinois
en attendant qu'un million deux cent
mille doses de vaccin soit livrée par le
mécanisme kovacs la bosnie doit
multiplier les commandes pour enrayer
l'épidémie en lui apportant leur aide
les serpents de la main aux bosniens ce
geste pourrait bien permettre aux deux
pays d'améliorer leurs relations
belgrade à d'ailleurs annoncé avoir
proposé un sommet bilatéral dans les
prochains mois dans le but de développer
notamment une coopération économique